SALMAN KHAN: Hi, my
name is Sal Khan.
I'm the founder and faculty
of the Khan Academy,
and we're trying to
educate the world.
Welcome to the presentation
on basic addition.
In August of 1789,
they've already
done their version of the
Declaration of Independence.
The process is called
photosynthesis.
I was tutoring my
cousins, literally,
and I had to figure out
a way to scale myself up.
So I started recording
YouTube videos,
and I started making little
software modules for them.
But I made it so
anyone could use them
and started getting
a lot of traction.
BILL GATES: What Sal
Khan has done is amazing.
He's taken all this material,
and broken them down
into little 12-minute lectures.
I use it myself to
remind myself of things.
I have children who like it.
So I was super happy
he came up, and we
got to talk about
where does he go now?
How can my foundation
help him pursue this dream
and connect it up with the
other great things going on
in the internet?
SALMAN KHAN: I want it to be a
standalone virtual school where
anyone in the world who
wants to learn anything
can go there, start
from the basics,
progress as far as
they need to go,
get feedback, get
assessment, get practice.
And eventually I want it to
actually become the operating
system for what goes on
in the classroom, where
every student's allowed
to work at their own pace,
and the teacher actually becomes
more of a mentor or a coach.
BILL GATES: So I see
Sal Khan as a pioneer
in an overall movement
to use technology
to let more and more
people learn things, know
where they stand.
It's the start of a revolution.
SALMAN KHAN: All of the
videos, they're all free.
Openly accessible.
www.khanacademy.org
BILL GATES: I think it's
a huge contribution.
Everybody should check it out.